[Music]
hello welcome back to the lobby games
spots weekly hangout every Tuesday at 2
p.m specific Pacific right here on
gamespot.com PX is over no more travel
for the video game price although it
seems to have taken its toll on my
partner in crime Mr Christopher Waters
hey hey folks I'm Chris Waters here at P
Prime uh here to cover um oh it's not
they didn't even cut to you before you
did that so nobody knows what happened
they saw it on the jib maybe hi guys
Kevin is here as well I'm sleepy but I
didn't go to packs why are you sleepy
then just because that's my general
state of being is it because you've been
playing L
batage for a week but mostly I'm just
I'm just lazy and tired have you been to
pack before no I've never been to P you
I I don't know there are a lot of people
there asking me about Kevin vanor if he
was at P I got to say in Seattle which
is a fine fine City it's great the the
the Windy apple as they call it the
windy Apple did you enjoy your pack
experience Chris H did you enjoy your
packs experience you were doing loads
you were hosting panels I did and and
losing hunger game tournaments The
Hungry Games panel was not a personal
highlight for me all right hosting
civilization beyond Earth panel was uh
and you guys can watch that tonight on
Gamespot it's going to post uh at 5:00 P
PM actually so like in three hours uh
but yeah like packs the Highlight
because like usually at packs most of
the game stuff has already been we've
gotten like the big chunks out of the
way at events like E3 and Gamescom and
stuff like that it's always about seeing
indie games which I got to do a little
bit but it's also about like talking
with you guys who come to the show which
is always really fun because they want
to talk about games and I talking about
games we talk about games it's really
strange it's like after going to E3 and
like in the past couple years having the
opportunity to do that going to Gamescom
going to PAX East as well for whatever
reason PAX Prime was like it's the most
fun I've ever had at a conference hands
down way better than E3 and everything
else and like it was just like the
internet like became physical because it
was like folks you've been talking on
Twitter for ages or in the Gamespot
community and then like video game
developers you've always wanted a me and
then like other like people who work on
our weird little video game website the
world and like YouTubers and then the
twitch guys and like it was it's just
like everyone's there all hanging out
yeah and the mega boot's great because
you could you walk in and you basically
just have dozens of Indie developers uh
and their games that you might not have
had access to before because all we ever
do is go to like the big straight shows
like bear zerkers like bear zerkers that
looks pretty good we we need to get a
copy of that and play it on the show
definitely yeah Sean played that bad boy
but anyway enough about that video games
are back Summer's over folks stop going
out and getting those sweet Sun Tans
mine's actually gone now so it looks
normal again yeah it's fall now you
you've changed into your fault skin it's
depressing my fall skin my skin is
falling off actually do not shave in the
shower cuz you'll just straight up cut
your face off yeah that's a wound it's
like where's the blood coming from do
you need to put some like ointment on
that maybe anyway sorry video games are
back and the first video game that's
coming out between now and Christmas
it's not even the first one of them is
the Sims and Kevin vanor has been
playing it Sims little the four Sims
game Sims the fourth Sims retail product
to ever be released how many expansion
packs are are for The Sims now like 23,
528,000 bear is I think how we're
supposed to pronounce that SP guessing
oh it's look Mary's actually wearing her
pink gloves right now as well it's
amazing it's
like I like but I I kind of like the uh
the galactic tights like what's going on
here I think that's the closest thing to
actual Mary representation that we will
have on this whole character model I I
am not uh responsible for that I'm not
responsible for this Danny that's pretty
supposed to be Danny that's pretty good
it's actually not terrible it's not a
it's not a bad Danny actually how's the
gut looking how big is the gut it's not
you know what you got to it's about
right it's about right right Rob might
have been a little bit generous there
but let's uh to me rather than to to my
G I did create my own Kevin oh you're
Waldo though so well you know I had to
go I kind of like being matchy sometimes
especially with the color red and the
color red I don't like the selection of
hats I like the red hat minus one on the
score you're wearing a red hat on your
character yeah but this I don't like
this style of hat I need an oldfashioned
baseball cap that's not one of those
wide Brim
travesties is there an Assassin's Creed
tattoo on his left on his no but there
is a tattoo if you want we can take yeah
I I add a I did add a tattoo let's see
if we can uh go into that let's yeah so
how is this character creation go have a
look at it's it's not bad the I'm I'm
sort of missed the uh customization we
used to have with the with the textures
and stuff like that and the colors um
that's been taken out which is kind of
sad only to be put back in at a later
date for paid
DLC is that is that a thing Kevin you
think going to happen uh maybe yes I
actually think that's a that kind of
looks like Peter Brown actually up
there so I can't uh so yeah but this I I
want to show you my walk because I'm
very I'm very pleased with my walk if I
can if I can remember how to uh how to
get into that you got this because I
really like my there's a lot of buttons
Happening Here There is a lot of buttons
so part there different walks that you
can choose I'm going to come to the side
here so we can really see so here's
here's default walking
I don't know if that's the how anyone
walks really here's perky walking all so
this is this is what I've decided to go
with because I think that has I think
that says a lot about me right there
sure it was between that and this oh
that's that's amazing but I really feel
like this captures the spirit now I was
I was thinking maybe we could create
Chris while we're while we're here do
you want to Chris are you are you down
for being Crea yes let's let's give that
a shot let's make it this is going to be
like the two 2 minute chis really no I
changed my mind what yeah because we
can't we can't do you justice can't
capture the ineffable Ence of we have
the genetics option and I'm kind of
thinking that maybe what would happen if
Kevin and Danny had a baby yes yes yes
that's if Kevin and Danny had a
baby should let's let's should we have a
son do you want a do you want a child or
do what would our child look like you
guys get a kid yeah look at that but
let's go through some randomization
options before we really get the sun we
think looks like I used to have a head
shave my head shaved that's that's
pretty yeah a little recessive jeans
there look the short shorts are killing
me yeah you you keep buying them for him
and I'm not into it okay now come on how
adorable is this little guy that's that
might be your winner there he looks more
Irish than I am well he does have the
green shirt on yeah and dungarees also
he's got a potato in his mouth he just
don't see it there can we make an
elderly version an elderly son it have
to be younger than parents it says I
don't know Universe they're living in so
here's there's teen I don't know I kind
of like oh hello stop that stop that how
do I go back how do I go back I don't
know how to go back it's too late go
back press press the dice in the in the
yeah once you disabled once you've had
children you can never go back all right
well we're I'm I'm fine with this child
okay I'm I'm absolutely fine with just
press X and build all right now this is
a good child I like this child let's uh
oh we have to we have to finish okay
it's going to make us finish all right
we're fine we're fine you're fine give
him a boy a suit suit dress him in a
suit okay so you've got different like
all right there's there's a little uh
Kevin Danny thing um we're done let's go
no do the walk do the walk oh I don't
know if we can do kids don't have walks
I don't think we can do the walks we can
pick aspirations do you think you should
be creative mental yeah
mental M or social Whiz Kids he wants to
be smart well I'm really
stupid um which means that he's in he's
a rambunctious scam I'm pretty sure that
our child would be a rambun Scamp sounds
about right so uh stop with the tips
thank you um let's uh let's select
something else that hobby hobby geek
music lover have you instilled in him
your uh my my my one of my personal
traits is music lover and geek is also
one of them you should have seen the the
Danny I created which we're not using
child was one of the uh was one of the
choices and I I gave Danny the childish
I like makes makes x- wings fly around
all right let's let's get let's get in
here let's get we have to name oh what
are we going to name him come on guys
decide this is that your child you're
sending off into the
world um how did it get vanor that's
[__] I don't it should be out wire
dongus
Mary awful name I'm good that aw I like
d of Mary that really says a lot
dungus VOR our child it's an it's a
traditional Irish name Danny it's a
family name wow our our family is going
to need more than 10 grand a year I feel
or dongus is going to starve to death
simoleons go really far in Willow Creek
you'd be
surprised does Mary have a male voice
Mary has a male voice and pink gloves so
she can clean up after dungus all the
time while the two of us are making more
babies am I
right science all right yeah
build that house oh you went to
customize the house a bit I don't you
know I don't think I think we really
need to see what kind of trouble cuz I
kind flirt with you I want to see what
happens like we're together that's true
clearly you know what though I didn't
feel like the third wheel I didn't
actually I didn't actually set up the
relationship okay like I feel kind of
bad that I didn't we had Rel so dongus
is a bastard you're yeah I mean people
will you guys D out of wock that it's
like you and Mary but we know the truth
we know the truth we know the truth we
know the truth I don't even know if that
is yeah here's Mary's watch she's
already watching TV she loves that TV
watching TV thinking about TV are there
four people Liv in this yeah totally
it's apartment it's the four of us
dongus is sleeping in you all three
sleep there or does Mary sleep on the
pullout bed I think we're going to find
I think Mary sleeps in the little bed
and the rest of us just all climb into
the other room that's dongus is room
Mary you're on the
couch all right let's get to let's get
to know you guys should get to know each
other she's living there as your beard
you might as well get to know her that's
a great walk I love the I know I'm I'm
I'm loving this
already dungus is bored already look at
him I want to talk I want to talk to you
I'm talking to Mary let's talk about
your favorite band I want to gon to go
interrupt hey guys you like my B you
guys like this band oh tell about this
sick band I heard you like tulle tell me
about t I'm really upset with Mary
getting in on my getting in on the on
the trouble let's see if we can get into
some trouble with her like what can I do
to be mean mischief mean to Mary let's
mock her musical taste Mary what bands
do you
like where's the real Mar those are
stupid bands they're they're stupid
bands your band is the worst Shia
Twain's a is a crack on it what you said
you like
Nickelback Justin Bieber and Nickelback
I'm not going to give her a heartfelt
compliment Kev you have totally F you
have just taken Danny's place now and
he's sitting at the table oh him and
dungus are having some reading time
together dongus let me read you a story
it's called how me and your dad had you
and science is
wrong this is the real world you live in
dongus know fascinating what happens is
the sperm mixes together and then a baby
appears science so listen to your
teachers they're all that's really gross
or exciting I'm not sure this is what
happens when you're mean to people in
your household you end up doing the
chicken dance by yourself on the couch
I'm going to yell at her now from across
the room oh we're having such a great
family stop with the toll tips oh you
acquired the comedy skill there being
such a
jokester all right let's see in the are
this are we homophobes is that what's
happened the three of us are like oh God
how can you be a homophobe we're
together Kevin go sit down with your
family at the table and stop watching TV
God I let's let sit down if this is
going to work you need
what can we do what's the Mischief
choices with the kid yeah D do you want
to start a Preposterous R lie about
career Preposterous rumor that he has
two daddies that did you see one he made
with super sperm one of them was Li at a
birthday party that's awful the kid lies
about the no you lied to the kid Li to
the kid about a birthday party yeah so
I'm told let's see if we can make him
cry dongus is going to maybe we can make
dongus cry oh man we're really you're
wreaking havoc on the emotional Dynamic
here Kevin achievements for getus to cry
I'm still trying to upset Mary she's I'm
really upset that she's not more upset
oh look we've turned I think we might
have we might have gotten your meter is
like let's yell at Mary your meter with
Mary is pegged on you know dungus has
really crap music taste as well we
should probably let him know should
probably point it out how else have a
shower Kevin have a shower all right
Chad oh Mary look at look at Mary's look
at how upset Mary is now look at her
she's calling him trash she's cranky she
is literally calling our child trash
she's like you are gutter trash all
right I want to be mean to her some more
and then I'll take a shower yeah it's
like real life I mean to people and then
I go shower Chad if you have any
suggestions in theer for the awful
things we can do uh please by all means
let us know in the gam Spot Shot or in
the oh Danny took out the trash slash
dumped it on his ankles look at that
look to the right slightly Kevin stop
being mean to Mary oh wait wait wait
wait wait what happened oh this is Danny
taking out the trash I'm an idiot um
guys I don't uh I put my hands on it and
it fell over I don't know what to do
next really maybe maybe Danny's the one
while I while I insult Mary maybe
Danny's the one that needs to take a
shower uh I got to go take a shower this
garbage is gross you want to take a
thoughtful shower a steamy shower a
Brisk shower or just a normal shower did
Mary just poop Mar just pooped on the
ground listen you stomped your foot and
garbage appeared underneath your butt if
that's not pooping I don't know what is
Mary is always dumping off the Game Spot
off it's like like it's like they made a
massive a perfect copy of and now Danny
and Mary are both going to take shower
going on again I'm going to scare Mary
let's see what happens if I scare
Mary not CU we're getting close to an
abor
confrontation oh she she is too she's
played PT Kevin you're going to have to
do better than that worst oh look at all
these new mean things I can do you want
scare mother as a Lama just tell her to
turn around o let's throw a drink
Kong they really
made oh
man Kevin is such a crazy
cat you are these high Jinks do it again
she's do it again is there anything more
interest imp implier mother is a
llama says the guy who just had a baby
with another dude broke her
heart your mom's a
llama that's more of an alpaka in the
drawing I don't know Vicky it doesn't
have the same ring though your mother is
an
alpaka Kevin you've got IDE fight
fight fight
fight oh Danny's coming Danny's here to
spread the good word nope he's just
going I like Bible in your in your you
just put the Bible away I guess there's
no God in this house dungus go to your
room I'm just I'm hoarding all the books
you playing librarian
again no I'm not begging for forgiveness
fight her
again TR fight her I really want a real
fight this you just made a wet tongue
slat fight oh here we go here we go here
we go oh man get after it yeah domestic
violence keep your hands off my
man I'm just looking I'm into it wow
this is this is quite a conflict where
is dungus can I fight dungus dungus went
outside still looking at the trash Oh
wait he's going to play in the trash
he's going to play in the poop mommy and
daddy you're fighting and I'm playing in
the
trash Oh wait there're
neighbors quick you need to go Danny go
meet the neighbors while Mary maybe
Danny should meet to meet the neighbors
talk to strangers dongus just like I
told you rud introduction yeah go over
and call that lady no that I did that
with you really it's uh
um let's see that doesn't look like a oh
she's coming over she h she heard some
screams she's just coming right in uh
hello neighborhood neighborhood police
hey what's going on everybody's going to
be rude to her these are everyone
everyone be get dungus to be rude to her
too where's dongus okay dongus is
outside playing in the in the trash joke
about chicken butt n wait no you're
you're interacting with Mary now not the
oh you're right I'm so sorry you're
right
okay everyone call that lady a [__] she
did just run into your house when
fight it's not your business
lady I feel like dongus has gotten off
life I'm start he's the child of Kevin
and Danny I wouldn't call that
light why is why is there an earthquake
in this I know it's really weird isn't
it I think there construction happening
if the camera start shaking we might be
having an earthquake if you hear a low
Rumble it's not because Kevin didn't eat
lunch it's because it's because I did
eat lunch noodle leg says should give
the lady a beat
down knock on her door who won the fight
marry or
Kevin oh you know what I don't really
know how that turned out Mary did so
let's it's kind of unclear Kevin's uh
gem has turned yellow that means he
probably got beat up a little bit right
cuz green means healthy yellow means got
your [__] yeah I've got my moodlets one
of my moodlets is I'm really unhappy
because I'm I'm I need to take a cold
shower you should go take a shower in
front of your neighbor okay
I'll take a cold
shower I got to cool off real hoad
vanord all right I think uh I think
we've given perhaps the most accurate
demo of your first few minutes with the
Sims 4 excuse me but I'm going to throw
a drink oh God just make D there's my
tattoo you wondering there we go yeah
totally D let's really get a good look
at Kevin in the shower
here yeah it enhance Zoom enance enhance
zoom in enhance we got some CS
uh computer technology here I'm just
going to zoom in and unpixelate that
exactly we can do that now we have the
technology dungus is all right dungus go
play in the garbage again yeah what is
what is filthy Street child what what
else can dungus do like I haven't done
Lake kids yet can he drown in the river
can't you can go fishing that's step
that's the first step towards drowning
in the river go near the river no first
thing is to get drunk okay can we get
dongus drunk we get
some I'm going to make him play maybe
he's going to dig up some buried booze
that the teens left
there you clean up the track standing a
garbage pile I'm talking about World of
Tanks I get on the side of the bed next
to the lamp you no I get on the side of
the bed next to the lamp so see they're
talking about bedroom things I feel like
this conversation would go better if you
weren't ankle deep in Mary's
poop the neighbor's picking up the poop
thanks neighbor
that's helpful she came over to my house
we called her names and then she oh she
set it down again Consolidated oh no
she's she's like getting your life in
order where's dongus picked up a capsule
you seriously need like a neighborhood
supervisor dungus just dug up some
drugs he dug up a drug stash and now
he's going to eat them like vitamins who
can oh he can play browse kidfriendly
websites how come there's not brows not
yeah go to uPorn all right I think we've
done enough with this wait can we make
me walk somewhere first because I really
haven't seen that walk in action in any
meaningful way Dan I think you said it
right this was definitely a good uh
slice of what it's like for someone just
starting to play The Sims do this weird
thing do this weird thing make make
everyone angry in the middle of a
conversation I want to see oh there goes
Danny for a joog and there we go there's
some there's some Kevin those Hips Don't
Lie hey dongus let me show you how to
find bags of me the teenagers dug up or
something I'm going to go fishing cuz
that's the man all right that's it
that's it we're done SS 4 out now right
yeah it's totally out you two can make
your happy family with children that
have really unfortunate names yeah
dungus I dungus is a name at all stupid
name you know how much
time terrible H I got the worst name
Preposterous I really do hate my name I
hate my last name with a passion I hate
it yay all right that was The Sims for
available now on Origin all you cool
kids looking something to buy on Origin
you got it we're going to be back in a
minute with with Mighty number nine but
first a traitor for a video game that's
coming out real soon that a bunch of
you'all going to be playing next week I
think
Destiny
Earth it's fair to say that by now we've
thoroughly explored our
planet but what if we could explore the
planets around us centuries from now
after we colonized them and then later
lost them to what came next Destiny
presents Planet
[Music]
view explore the
future discover our
enemies uncover hidden
treasure and see what else you can
[Music]
find go to Destiny planet.com
Destiny planet.com there's something to
do while you wait for Destiny Justin
hayal I did Destiny Planet view you did
I saw the planets I was a little
disappointed I mean it's cool it's I I
saw Mar I walked around Mars it's more
like street view like I was expecting
more of a Google view where like you go
into the planet and then I was I just
wanted to zoom all the way out yeah but
it's more like you can zoom out a little
bit and then you just walk along the
street
which is cool are you looking forward to
Destiny tentatively okay I I'm not as
sold on it as other people I do want to
be a warlock and run around space
because that's just absolutely
ridiculous you play a bunch of the beta
yeah tell me what are you looking
forward to it because I'm actually I'm
still in that I'm not a big Halo guy and
I'm still sort of a little bit apathetic
to it I don't think I'd be looking
forward to it as much if I didn't have
like if I had a game that I was really
interested in right now which I kind of
don't really I'm a little bit between G
games to like put a bunch of time into
so what about
Sims yeah I'm not really a simy you know
what it's the Sims had come in earlier
in the summer I probably would have
spent a lot of time on us but it's just
it's come out right before coming on
everything popping off but yeah I am
excited for Destiny I have some friends
who are really excited for it so it's
going to be I'm excited because it'll
give us an opportunity to play something
together online which we haven't really
you know mechanically the game didn't
thrill me when it was it was F it was F
fine and functional but like
and I I had fun towards the end of the
beta but you know it hasn't lit my fire
yet but I'm definitely going to get into
it I'm looking try and see like how much
people play it like if this is something
that everyone in the office is playing
then of course to play it's going to be
one of those event games that like
everyone's into it like at the moment
it's sitting pretty number one on the
Gamespot 50 as well so it's it's the the
most popular game on the side at the
moment and certainly by you're looking
at like previews and and and and
trailers and whatnot like everyone's
watching it so it is kind of feels like
that event game thing everything we
write about about it people just like
eat it up they want to know more about
what's happening with the game so any it
could still be really big Co and of
course it will be big when it comes out
how long is that going to last though
that's what's important to me and we'll
probably check it out next week on the
lobby right exacto but right now Justin
hey wal you're here we are going to play
some of the mighty number nine uh once
that controller gets fixed here give me
that give me throw it over there oh
bit Jas Jason Justin hay Jason
hay l batage h Justin here to pay Mighty
number nine bit of backstory for this
this is uh Kickstarter obviously it was
kjun his latest works the creator of
Mega Man put together a like he left
Capcom everyone was always saying like
you know what game I want I want a Mega
Man game and years and years went by and
he did not deliver it for whatever
reason I'm sure there was a lot of stuff
going on but he left Capcom and the
first thing that he did was start a
Kickstarter for a Mega Man game I mean
to to be completely honest this is a
spiritual successor to to Mega Man and
even calling it Mighty number nine you
have a cute guy with a gun who jumps
around and very cartoony but the way
that the game plays like it it doesn't
feel exactly like a Mega Man game it
feels not not even like an extension it
feels like an evolution of that series
it's paying tribute to Mega Man but but
doing it in in a way that feels new and
different in a lot of ways I remember
when this uh Kickstarter started it was
one of the sort of controversial ones
when they were asking for what seemed
like a lot of money but you know it was
it was n they asked for $900,000 yeah
which for any game is seems pretty you
know that's that's not majorly outside
of the realm of video game budgets like
that seems like I mean when you ask for
that much money that seems to be like I
need enough money to get started and
then we hope to find a publisher yes
exactly but but they ended up raising
over $3 million super successful uh and
people have been really excited to try
it out and I and I guess so we were just
at PA kg neun had a panel and at the
panel he announced that the beta is now
going out if you back to the game on
Kickstarter you're going to be able to
jump in and if you back to the level
where you get to play the beta you can
start playing it and if you went to any
of his panels you also get to try it out
that's crazy so we're going to try it
out right now M number nine controller's
working let's do this so it's funny so
this is very much more of a Japanese
beta you have to push uh you have to
push B to go forward normally you know
you push a in American games but in
Japanese games you tend to have to push
the circle I was used to annoy me when I
play menus like metal GE your solid
demos and whatnot we're all about that I
guess I probably should have learned how
to play the game so so Peter's the one
who took the uh who took the demo for
this but he's feeling a little bit sick
he's feeling a little under the weather
probably is the Pack Box let's be honest
yeah we banished him from the office the
thing the the hook in this game is being
able to dash through enemies so you hit
a guy now like you see how he turned
kind of blue you can Dash through him
whoops and then you kind of absorb their
power so blue is I think
health and it lets you get through them
a little bit faster this is first level
of the game this is the okay green yes
so the beta is just this one stage oops
are is there any way that capcom's not
going to try to take some legal action
against this situation not not at this
point this this dude looks hella like
Mega Man saying he's definitely Mega Man
looking but Mega Man doesn't Dash
through enemies so you just saw I picked
up that red power up I had a green one
it's running out use your fire powers
makes you a little bit stronger hits
enemies quite a bit harder are you about
to chain those jumps once yep so you
can which there'll be some platforming
coming up where you'll definitely have
to do that and you have to be careful
with these blocks cuz they will fall on
you if you shoot through
them take that blocks and it's early so
there is a there's kind of a bottom
slide like that kind of sliding on his
face oh my God the chin chaping H Peter
was telling me before we we've set the
graphics to like relatively near the low
end of the scale because apparently the
beta is it's pretty choppy well
optimized yeah he was he was capturing
footage earlier in the office beta thing
yeah it it looked pretty bad it looked
pretty you got like a dash situation or
something a dash situation I don't know
that's what doesn't that doesn't that
green thing look like it's sail yeah so
the green lets you move a little bit
faster yeah that's what I'm talking
about man so I can move a little bit
faster now oh no I'm running out of the
red those explosions will hurt you as
well you move a he feels like you move a
little bit slow look at that guy it's
another version of you oh jerk who that
helicopter guy
yeah
Jay did you play much uh did you play
much Mega Man back in the day or the new
ones
even uh oh back in the day no I was
actually never a really big Mega Man
person not especially not as much as
Peter and those guys what about you
Chris I didn't have a Mega Man type
system back in the day uh we are the
best people to be playing this video
game so I played a little bit you know
at friends houses and stuff but I did
not have access to it in my on my home
turf how long how long is this demo this
is the first time it's been playable
this is the first time that that
everyone's been able to play it so
probably about 10 15 minutes to get
through it one other interesting thing
that you didn't necessarily have in uh
in the Mega Man games is that as you
collect these items you see when I pause
I have a stock of items I have health
stock one and two you can use that to
refill your health what that's hack
hacks hack or wait do you still have
that go back go back to men using like a
health potion no I I used it once it's
gone now all right we're
just oh congratulations
to nice work let's do that a little a
little bit faster this time oh hey
Justin no need to show that's amazing
what what was in that tips menu uh don't
exit mid game without
saving fair enough what was what was in
there uh you know telling you how to
play how like how this dash part works I
didn't read through that so I actually
don't
know I played it a little like Peter was
like Hey I'm feeling sick I can't make
it through yeah uh can you play the game
for me and I said oh okay uh people
can't get access to this at this stage
right if they were like B into the Beta
now if they bought into the Beta they
can do it right they can play right now
but I guess they can't now because
Kickstart is not like Indiegogo where
they have closed
entrance to the yeah you're not going to
be able to to keep doing this so like
it's it's a bit of a closed thing now
but if you were at packs and you happen
to drop by the their Booth uh you would
have gotten the chance to get this as
well do you know when cuz this is this
beta is accessible via steam uh so do
you know if this is coming out in the ne
in the near future or cuz I'm wondering
if they'll they'll be tempted to go
towards the Early Access route as well
on this one I I don't think they've
given us a date on the full game yet
it's a weird thing where some developers
once they kind of as long as they get
their Kickstarter people early they kind
of don't mind opening it up and it's
becoming more uh like acceptable to do
that now to like do a later Buy in once
at least the kickstarter people have
been like serviced first as it was one
way to put it you mean the yeah so as
long as you've satisfied you did that
last time where you stood next to the
barrel and shot it I thought you were I
don't learn from my mistakes okay fair
enough uh April 2015 is the release days
apparently uh they apparently it's still
coming out on all of these ridiculous
consoles uh 3DS uh Linux Mac PS3 PS4 uh
VA Windows 360 Xbox One and they also
apparently releasing it on uh the
Nintendo ehop for uh for or the Nintendo
store for for Wii U um I'm not sure if
if they're going to end up staggering
those I would knowbly think
so it's not that big a team making it
either all right go to title yeah that's
it yeah let's do that again almost did
it again almost did it no just you know
what in the full version they'll
probably have a are you sure text box
pop up so if Mr infun is watching right
now please
sir pleas please protect us from
ourselves if not for for for uh Justin
and for the rest of us watching do you
see Mighty number five talking to me in
the background there he taunting me
telling me how much I suck wait who what
Mighty number five so you're mighty
number nine in this game uhhuh there
other mighties yeah you have to fight
all the other I am number one or four
whatever that was see that movie I Am
yeah no I didn't see it but I was
ringing a bell you listen that robot was
just peacefully going about its crate
carrying business you busted its crate
of course it's going to get
mad he was he that was a crate of death
just joking delivering doing jokes oh
man look at the it's the Z
AIS axis was that another someone
helping you in the back they like froze
those dudes Jason Jason Jesus Christ P
you know what's happened ever since
everyone started calling you J now I'm
calling you Jason for absolutely no
reason Jason hey there's too many there
too too many J names in the office
you've called him like three different
things on this show so
far a
dongus complete this level already
dongus
we're going to let you try and complete
the uh complete the SP have you
completed it before uh yes I ran through
it once right a little bit before the
show all right so you'll notice that if
you don't absorb the guys they do they
do
disappear oh no how do you feel about
this cuz I'll be honest this looks like
super
generic I'm not I'm not totally into it
I feel like these games are best served
when they are difficult so perhaps
because this is like the early level
you're not really getting the best it up
but I did get to play through this
already so I I had a lot more trouble uh
the first time that I tried this oh no
and the controls are a little
interesting it's you get used to it but
interesting huh that doesn't sound
positive interesting sounds like a
really nice way of saying crappy oh one
hit so the spikes are all one hit deaths
okay back to the start not all shouldn't
go all the way back to the start yeah I
don't have to go that far back you die
one more time we're pcing out of this
again Gang Beast we mentioning to people
Gang Beast a player is the most
difficult thing to set up ever we had it
working earlier uh currently it looks
like we only have about five lights on
these controllers we might just do a
four player game but uh in any case
we'll get into that in a minute Justin I
believe in you except I mean you shot
the I I'd be honest I'm not actually
believing in him that much at the
moment you can do it you can do it
dongus nice okay it's getting a little
bit more difficult
now and then we're going to come up
against the boss the boss is a very
standard Mega Man kind of enemy is it
okay or he has has a patter go get the
secret get the
secret oh yeah belly slide oh that guy
you up what is that thing an extra
life oh you drops you right on the bomb
gives you an extra life and then drops
you onto a mine
great that's it see you suckers later no
need to got time for this number five
taunting me again number five is a
jerk is are you fighting number five
have you have they gone Rogue oh this do
look too good is number five the boss
number five is going to be the boss of
this stage oh no do you end up fighting
all of them oh whoa good save nice
dashing oh that dude's boned oh no he
does that dude's
bone you're in a tight spot come on you
can do it do you have any health stops
left I do
not and maybe he'll give me
some yeah eat it maybe take them from
you forklift garbage can nope he gave me
fire I might not make it I do not have
health the last Justin I believe in you
I believe in you
Jason we believe in both Justin and
Jason so whoever you're feeling like
today and dungus I don't believe in
dungus dungus is a myth oh oh no all
right you got one more chance where did
Mary even come up with that name the
name of her
child
Mighty number nine coming to every
console known to mankind April
2015 you got domed by a missile Justin
hey wals thank you very much for coming
onate H make sure to punch Peter Brown
in the arm next time you see him he is
the Mega Man Master if he had been
playing this he would have probably beat
it one run he's a speedrunner he just
went home like a real dungus and we will
have more coverage of the mighty number
nine for Mr Peter Brown hopefully later
in the week if you're watching Peter
first of all I hope you're not you
should be in bed second of all get well
soon there is an article up on the site
right now about it oh there is there you
go bam see I just made it happen read it
unbelievable all right we'll going to be
back in a second we're going to try uh
fix up some gang be see how many these
controllers we can get going we'll be
back in a minute check out trailer
please yeah I'm different I'm different
yeah I'm different I'm different yeah
I'm different
pull up to the with my pull up to the my
roof when I leave the your Bo and I be
like a new song but I got me a
[Applause]
everything
and
[Applause]
going I'm yeah
[Music]
I'm what's up y'all sorry to keep you
waiting can we get a can we get a white
shot of this madness I love this H we've
tried to get a player hey what's up Rob
all these get back to
work the yeah we've tried to get a
player at Gang Beast working it's been a
nightmare we have one one two three
four five six seven maybe seven wow we
might have pulled this off I don't know
we'll see we'll see how many are
controllable okay H can you get the
cursor off the screen the mouse key
that's why this last one might not be
okay could you bring up the keyboard as
well let's try and do that we don't need
it now that could be might need it for
the game go get it for you might go
crazy person I'll get it I'll get it
I'll I'll get it okay I can control this
all right let's go to this Gang
Beasts controllers do you have I don't
know yet we're going to find out uh can
we do it in costumes or we goe straight
to versus just go to verse try a player
see what happens yeah do uh do like five
let's do eight and see how many we got
we're going test them all try it start
Johan mckin is ready to rumble okay this
guy works this guy works this guy works
this guy oh this guy works one works are
these oh we got seven got and the
keyboard mouse would be eight yeah this
one works okay more everyone pick up a
controller Sean put a microphone on okay
he's not is he going to be miked up I
don't know we got
microph back up to the menu Tay back up
to the menu we got another controller
for somebody here we got one more Ty you
want to come on yeah all right Ty come
on here here I'll take the keyboard
mouse anything goes g we got one more
who else wants to come is anyone back
there yo Jeremy come here Jeremy's just
walking through the stud I'll just leave
at the end here we go it's fine which uh
station should we start on uh do um okay
back up for a second back to the menu
back to the menu back to the menu quiet
for a sec back to the menu K back to the
screen there we go here we go that's
dangerous everyone watching the live
stream will know how badly organized but
also amazing this was but nobody else
will
know such is The Wonder of video I am
surprised let's come back to
Wi get off the gameplay yeah he wants
all the way oh hold on I can tell him
Josh he wants the wide no gameplay
no get on the horn there you go yeah hey
what's up Gang Beast came out of ear it
came into Early Access and we got our
own gang of beasts right here H one of
the new feat gesticulating in my face
all right one of the nice features they
have is the ability to play with eight
people we have 1 two three four five six
seven eight oh we actually have eight
it's all the left in this company H also
they have costumes let
ticket nice nice H they also got
costumes look at these ones let's just
leave them as they are oh yeah and head
into sounds good what's going on over
here oh you you took control off me man
you're doing it now no it's everybody oh
is it really that's why that's why only
one person needs to drive drive okay so
we can do up to eight people let's go
survival is doing mode at the moment y
let's do three lives at what stage we
doing anything but grind don't grind we
oh cycle
stages no because if you get grind it's
going to get real bad let do trucks for
now let's do trucks for now trucks is
the worst TR is the worst you ready
incinerator incinerator okay I'm purple
I'm
purple who am I am yeah see you later oh
I was oh yeah oh God I'm still on get
out of
here I'm going to stand on you get help
you're coming with me oh no the jump oh
no you have to make the
jump I was winning a
sign uh hold on do you guys kind of know
who you are now I know EXA okay everyone
stop nobody hit anyone else I'm Godzilla
the green one I'm oh you so who's going
get out of here I'm purple I'm the guy
who jumped the gun who's red how do you
do what's the lift button
no we each other Chris get off my truck
you get off of me I have no
idea who made this that was me did you
just hit the deck is that went
unconscious I win do you have to jump as
well once it comes
ites boom who's this right here I just
got wiped out immedi this chicken get
out of here fly
homeo wo I'm winning woo let's go me
let's just I'm not dead yet I'm Not Dead
Yet die I'm going to
survive yes yes no I want too I'm on the
side
I survived because you still on I
survived I'm still on I survived because
no you're
both Sean is hiding on the other side of
the
truck two lives left is were you holding
on he's just to the side of the truck I
didn't know you're hold on that long
that's fine okay let's go for inator
incinerator yeah incinerator that one is
is there any new ones they've added no
wheels good to Subway is also super good
what was vents just choose one
immediately okay let's do
this okay I'm going to go in the shop
nobody nobody touch me get out of it's
my it's my shop go do it Chris damn it
who's this damn it who's this brown guy
get out of here I'm still good I'm still
good
guys good let's help him why won't you
die I don't want to die oh no
wait oh wait bashing my attack I hope no
let me go don't throw me I'm your I'll
fire you oh no I lost my what happened
to Green come over here what I'm right
here just jumping around like a lizard
it's a little lizard party wonder what's
up here no don't throw me in the fire
you [__] get me
off get in there [__] you they've done
the lighting up as well it looks way
better die
lizard I play I'm Not Dead Yet chicken
you let go me you you get out of
here kill that oh wait wait wait wait wa
wait P what are you doing Pikachu
Pikachu over the top rope how do you how
do you lift them over the Rope again you
P both bumpers hold both bumpers and
then y to raise someone over your head
and then you use your momentum to like
don't come in here I'm going to give you
the people's elbow don't come in here
who's who's the purple guy hang who's
shopping it's been we' figured it out oh
it's a tussle in the door a door
he's holding me and the door this is
preposterous finish him W right here me
and Pikachu brought the door into the
match how are you still holding on to me
you're
unconscious a goodp you guys
ARP get in get in come on my [__] my
door my door it's like your door your
door door oh no Dino no I'm out of here
you are just hopping and flopping come
on from the top
rope you want a piece of this somebody
just killed two people please please oh
they're getting sad because they're dead
oh do it we all just got knocked
[Applause]
out you let go right now Pikachu your
days are purple guy come on purple guy
finish the
job woo woo should do wheel wheel
is sorry my M but that's it's
fine get in there teal oh no
way who's the dinosaur me who's in the
[__] who's in the shop get away from
me
Fez I accidentally held onto the wall
yeah I did that too get out of my shop
let's get you out of here get out of my
shop everyone chasing dinosaur stop come
here
time to go extinct get in there son of a
[__] you're coming with me you're
coming with me oh no SoMo off the
[Applause]
balcony coming with
Meo SoMo was going back up top yes he
will perch and
wait I'm going for you Som you still
come get yeah he's a je you want a piece
of me everyone ban together to get some
BR some look at him he's not doing
anything wait Sean is that is that you
Mary's Mary's sitting in the store the
whole time that's
me leave me alone Danny I was the
chicken I don't want any part of
you take him out guys SoMo get
him the
Pikachu get out
my get in there you Dam it he just cold
coed oh I'm down I'm down but I'm not
out
top Hat's holding
on coming with
meiku oh well deserved oh my goodness
dang it what
Ace that was I think the S is an
advantage cuz it it's it's stopped your
head from falling down yeah no all right
Pikachu you're going down bring it
on oh
no no is that you and red Ty back off
come
on oh no see a SoMo oh wait Pikachu we
can talk let's talk leave me alone Danny
let's talk oh God come here D oh
no get away from me
chicken God dang
it no no no don't leave me alone stop
beating me damn it I'm dead hey leave
that brown guy alone oh my
God pick him up ouch damn it
bird get off of me
bird let's agree to take out the dino I
don't know Dino is no threat to you let
go of my Dino junk somebody go after Ty
just oh no I don't know how to lift oh
get out of here Top Hat I'll see you in
h get out of here you're staying with me
bur you're coming with me Chris I I know
what the lift button is on the keyboard
or Mouse who's the chicken what are you
doing
chick right now oh my God I might look
like a how do I get him off of me he
won't let go don't you [__] touch me
I swear still holding on I'll never let
go throw his ass into the fire it's just
bring me back up bring me back up he
can't he won't let go just bring me back
up he literally can't get him off my
stupid
hand no quit running away it's between
Ty and Son of AIT
and it's why oh my God I think it's why
amount of
screaming just let here we go Ty and
Mary who's bird bird is Mary Ty is red
come on Ty is the coward be in the chick
but one of us is chicken I'm not even
going to give
you not even going to give you the
pleasure who's left the mental the
mental
game fear fear feure mental
game okay one at a time notify yourself
when you pop up oh no we out what
happened the game was just like F this
you all suck you guys all right try back
out see if we can get it we got one more
game oh you got it Play One More on
Wheel again yeah wheel do wheel so this
game is on Early Access it's published
by double find but it's made by what's
the really small Dev team they they got
a chicken leg as their logo they've
they've had this in uh they've had this
in beta on a couple of Indie sites for
the past while but yeah it's $15 at the
moment it's down from 20 if you get in
nice and early yeah we played it on
multiple players a few months ago and it
was a different build uh there it was a
little more sluggish uh they've sort of
picked it up a little bit Yeah lighting
looks way better too are we all the same
just the nor there can I get off yes be
careful the wood isn't too good down
there yeah watch out said let let Ty run
around let him let him figure it
out Sean did you we just punch each
other out oh no you weren't joking about
that wood Top Hat wood is no Sean never
jokes around when it comes to Wood oh no
it's see I holding on I mean to do that
Yow I'm coming for
you you are destabilizing my entire
platform this is weird are you stuck on
the I'm stuck on look at me I'm hanging
I'm stuck oh there we go damn it lizard
hey guys
oh I'm getting crushed I'm getting
crushed pretty bad yeah you're coming
with you are coming
with oh yeah you're coming with me
you're coming with me I'm I won't you
Pikachu I'm going to Tay drag you into
the ocean oh you're feisty oh no oh no
you're coming with you're coming with me
into the stamina enjoy running out of
stamina you do you do but knock off
sometimes you don't who's Som brero you
son of a
did not run out of stamina when he was
holding on to me I'm com for you I'm
coming for
you here it comes daddy oh
[__] I really thought I had a move there
[__] uhoh uh oh no good are Mary and
Chris still there at the edge yeah Mary
tried to throw me off but I'm holding on
with a death
grip oh [__] yeah all of you just died
oh you your maybe no I'm holding on with
my hands okay die Waters God damn it I
we zoom in this all right come on I
can't die somebody one of you take one
for the for the stream I'm trying I'm
trying to punch Mar push the bumpers
yeah smash the bumpers and jump a lot
come on can do let go I returned to the
Briny D
yeah chicken you got to find Top Hat no
he's dead no I don't think he is he's
you have to let go very much alive he's
holding on been holding on this whole
time he's in the top holep no no no over
there you don't see anything no he's off
to the left yeah he's right
underneath no he found me you can't get
me anyway kick it come get you got to
just get rid of all the wood oh
no wins i k him I killed him he lost the
L that's fine go that's fine that's all
that
matters oh man red I'm coming for you
from the top
room [__] sh boom you can't handle my
Elite lizard
tactics who's this oh man Fez I need to
I need it's me hey Rob we haven't
foughten this yet we haven't fought at
all no you think he won already come
here you oh you son of a [__] get out
of here Rob's been talking some mean
smack about how much he knows about this
game let oh my God they're going down
the hole they're all Down in the
Hole
dou punch
pun oh God what were you saying a little
earlier
Mary it's on now oh no fall in that
whole Loser come here crap Zack no damn
face in my face oh no fall off Up
R who's
somero why do you keep asking that
question you know who somero is
oh yeah he
is okay Chris and Sean no no let go ofo
oh oh don't forget Brown
guy so they call you top
hat no no dump him no try hold try
hold good luck down there
[__] oh one chicken is still here on
right there chicken is still hanging on
on chicken damn it chicken chick chicken
the Ed oh
I heard I heard the splash Sean you're
going to yeah I'll meet you down here I
feel like you can glide in your hat is
that like a super power you got oh we go
oh
no
it's peace peace peace peace some wins
again that was a good throw everyone go
for Sombrero let's go for
SoMo right there he's in the BR one come
on come on in oh he's going
[__] no oh nice one brown
guy a It's Quickly backfired oh he's on
top of you want some of this get in this
come on come get in here I'm going to
rock your boat son are you Jes Spiderman
over here come on in I'm coming to get
you I'll bring you in come here I'm
pulling you down no oh no you can run
over here I come to save the day hang on
Danny hang on hang on Danny I have no
quals with you
all right all right he's gone I'm going
I'm going after him come on try to get
me oh god oh no I'm hanging on again I
didn't mean to do that yeah I uto H on
last time I do not trust you one I don't
trust you give me your hand I I see youo
get you
no stuck I you dumb piece of [__] lizard
I'm stuck on this thing still good I
think I might still be there I didn't
hear what's happening to Sombrero it's
upside
down oh no don't fall somero is just
fine on
somero I am straight up stuck onto
this somero is De they're falling
they're falling [__] is it just me and
chicken
Pikachu Pikachu doing a very Flawless
piku on
uhoh yeah oh no oh no the ferris wheel
he's struggling oh no oh Pikachu finish
the job go
go chicken wi and it's chicken for oh
wait SoMo where are you no SoMo just had
one left so this will be the final match
sha mckinness into somero Mary Kish on
the chicken here
times making a b taking a bold move
what it's a Bald Move cotton holding on
to the outside from
above he did
die come down here and fight me come on
Stupid Drunk
baby it was very elegant worst character
so
elegant oh man I was so excited that's
great the old rope and dope nice one
straight back to the
thanks back to the gy Gang Beast
available now Alpha
0.1.2
One someone turn their controller have
um if you have one friend or seven of
them uh I think you probably should get
this game that's the lobby for this week
thank you very much for hanging out
thanks for hanging out all drink packs
thanks for all you Jokers for hanging
out too Danny I have an announcement to
make that I mentioned earlier I just
want to say it again civilization beyond
Earth uh the panel live from well that
we recorded live at Pax is going up on
the site in two hours and it's got like
all sorts of great Civ beyond Earth
information in it so go go to watch it
there on
gamespot.com video games.com I'm done
great our Hunger Games panel may not
ever be available to see because the SD
card broke we're trying to fix it watch
this space H all right we're all going
to go off and probably play some more
gang pie off the live stream H have a
great week folks we'll see you next time
adios Mary don't mess up the JY shot oh
yeah Mary you got it smooth up get the
bunny ears in there yeah
why you
[Music]
playing